[Music]
on this Saturday night Israel's
Relentless
attacks the destressing scenes in
southern Gaza as talks to broker a new
pause break down this unfair life unfair
War plus the family of a Canadian woman
believed to be held hostage by Hamas
demands Ottawa does more to help I
really need them to help their own
Canadian cop 28 call to action the clock
is no longer just ticking it is banging
the battle against critics opposed to
climate change convention tension the
Ontario liberals top pick to unseat Doug
Ford and where is Ontario's missing
marsupial hopping to next wasn't too fun
uh I was doing my best but uh you know
I'm just a guy with a net so how do you
catch up with a
kangaroo
global national with forign Asser good
evening to you thanks for joining us
hopes are fading for a new humanitarian
pause for a second straight day Israel
ramped up its assault hitting hundreds
of Hamas targets inside Gaza even more
than before the now expired 7-Day long
pause gazin are on the move but as the
fighting rages on around them the UN
says there is simply nowhere safe to go
residents of Kan yunes were tens of
thousands of civilians fled to in the
last month say the southern city is
being hammered by Israel's heaviest
bombardment since the start of the
conflict a UNICEF spokesperson there
calls it an ongoing war on children the
UN estimates there are 50,000 pregnant
women in Gaza with 180 giving birth
daily the pause in fighting allowed for
the release of0 hostages and some 240
Palestinian prisoners but now with the
war renewed and even ramped up there are
growing concerns over the dozens of
hostages that are still under Hamas
captivity hostages the militant group
now says will not be released until
there is a ceasefire in Gaza and among
them is believed to be a Tana woman her
daughter says the Canadian government
isn't doing enough to help Karen
liberman has tonight's top
story hello to been 57 days is she alive
is she dead is she in a dark cave uh t
underneath the ground for weeks Iris
Weinstein hoggy has wondered and worried
about her mother Judy a Canadian Israeli
last seen here leaving kibuts n o the
morning of October 7th with husband God
she's now more concerned than ever with
this new information I got a recording
of uh Mada um speaking to my mom Mada is
an equivalent of uh like an Israeli Red
Cross speaking in Hebrew and in pain
Weinstein had called for
help my mom was very very graphic about
what happened to my dad um he was
basically murdered and my mom was shot
in her arm shot in her face moments
earlier the couple managed to record
this cell phone
video as Rockets stre through the sky
and gunfire erupted and Iris received a
WhatsApp message we are outside fa down
in the field since then no word though
the family believes Judy may have been
taken captive they're urging the
Canadian government to help rescue the
retired English teacher turned
mindfulness instructor who grew up in
Toronto and may be severely wounded I
really need them to help their own
Canadian the only Canadian citizen
that's hostage in Gaza in a statement
Global Affairs Canada said it's aware of
reports a Canadian citizen is missing in
Israel and officials are in contact with
the family and local authorities what do
you think is helping her get through
this I'm hoping she's using every bit of
mindfulness she uses every day and she
knows that we are thinking about her
that we're doing everything to get her
out of there just you know call her name
Judy Weinstein we need you back when
need you back Mom we miss you so much
Karen Lieberman Global News
Toronto Israel has now recalled its team
of negotiators in katar after reaching a
dead end in truce talks Danielle hamam
Jen reports from Jerusalem and a warning
tonight that some of the images you're
about to see are
disturbing the pounding of Gaza has been
Relentless Israel says it's struck 400
targets Across The Enclave since the
ceasefire ended early Friday
morning its military offensive is
Shifting to the southern half of the
strip where most of gaza's 2 million
people are crammed and hoping that death
doesn't come before the next potential
ceasefire he can't understand he can't
imagine the kids and the children and
the
womans what what's the problem with them
it's unfair life unfair
world the health Ministry run by Hamas
says 70% of the 15,000 dead are women
and
children hamas's numbers have been
considered generally reliable in
previous conflicts too many innocent
Palestinians have been killed frankly
the scale of Civilian suffering and the
images and videos coming from Gaza are
are
devastating Washington also made it
clear it will not allow the forced
relocation of Palestinians from Gaza or
the redrawing of gaza's
Border in the first shelling they told
us to evacuate to the South because it
would be safer said this man now they
tell us to go further south and into the
Sinai this is nonsense we will go
nowhere we will remain here the Israeli
military put out a map carving up Gaza
into hundreds of small areas ahead of
evacuation warnings I reject the comment
that there aren't safer places in the
gansa strip precisely because we have
specifically designated these places the
maps are there people can see where they
are and where people can go
to the Israeli military claims Hamas has
launched more than 250 rockets at Israel
since the ceasefire
[Applause]
ended
meanwhile a trucks crossed into Gaza
bringing in desperately needed food
water and medical supplies they came
from Egypt which for now is still home
to those photographed in one of the most
indelible images of the war there is an
update on those premature babies who
became a symbol of the suffering at
alifa hospital in Gaza
City here they are now healthier heavier
the majority of the 16 babies who were
transferred to Egypt last month have now
recovered Israel believes Hamas leaders
have now fled to the South and are
hiding among civilians one of their Most
Wanted men Yahya sinir the political
leader of Hamas who was thought to have
planned the October 7th attack far
Danielle Haman in Jerusalem tonight
thank you
Danielle and there's been a flare up in
fighting along Israel's northern border
with Lebanon Israel's military and the
iran-backed mil militant group Hezbollah
reintensification
is refueling fears the Israel Hamas
conflict will spark into a wider Middle
Eastern
conflict and today two Iranian
revolutionary guards serving as military
advisers in Syria are said to have been
killed in a Israeli rocket strike near
Damascus a pair of powerful earthquakes
rattled the southern part of the
Philippines today forcing thousands of
people to flee their
[Music]
homes the US Geological Survey measured
the first Tremor at a magnitude of 7.6
followed shortly by a 6.4 magnitude
Aftershock thousands in the country's
second largest island of mindo evacuated
their homes and businesses and even
hospitals as the Tremors sparked tsunami
warnings in the region that threat is
said to have passed possible damage from
the Quakes is still
unclear in Germany a fierce winter storm
has stranded thousands of
Travelers heavy snow grounded flights
and canel long distance trains in Munich
officials estimate more than 40 cmers of
snow fell overnight Downing trees and
cutting power to thousands across the
state of Bavaria no serious injuries
have been
reported in Dubai member nations
attending the cop 28 climate Summit have
reached agreements on renewable and
nuclear energy in an effort to cut back
greenhouse gas emissions now that
includes this country which has sent
hundreds of delegates to attend this
year's high-stake Summit but climate
groups are raising red flags about who
is representing Canada at this year's
events Abigail ban
explains keep the 1.5 degree Target
Within Reach a number of promises at cop
28 Saturday the clock is no longer just
ticking it is
banging and we must make up for lost
time another $3 billion pledged by the
United States €2.3 billion EUR from the
EU nearly 120 countries now say they'll
triple renewable energy by 2030 and
about 20 pledge to Triple nuclear energy
by 2050 Canada has signed on to both the
oil and gas industry must align around
our North Star of keeping 1 .5 wouldn't
reach but the presence of the Canadian
oil and gas industry at the summit has
climate groups sounding the alarm fossil
fuel industry sends um their Executives
because they want to um you know delay
and distract the conversations
environmental defense crunched the
numbers from this un document listing
the tens of thousands of participants
and found 35 people connected to
Canadian Oil and Gas under Canada's
Banner more than four times as many as
last year a government Source tells
Global News the official Federation
delegation doesn't include any oil and
gas reps saying they're part of
provincial delegations the feds don't
control although they do ultimately View
and approve the lists the reality is it
doesn't say Alberta bad and it doesn't
say Saskatchewan bad it says Canada it's
um honestly naive to think that there's
any path to Net Zero that doesn't engage
the biggest sources of emissions
Pathways Alliance a Consortium of
Canada's biggest oil Sands companies
says it's important to be part of the
conversation and their focus is on
technology that can be used to reduce
emissions we're here in a 100%
collaborative and constructive way we
already have a net zero plan on Monday
Canada will announce new regulations to
reduce methane emissions by at least 75%
by 2030 the US just released theirs
promising nearly an 80% reduction and
everyone is watching for when Canada
will announce its larger framework for
an oil and gas emissions cap Abigail ban
global news
Ottawa members of the Ontario Liberal
Party have now picked a new leader after
wrapping up the vote of its leadership
race
tonight after three rounds of ranked
ballot counting at tonight's convention
Miss Saga mayor Bonnie cromby is now set
to hm the party Ki dominated with the
most points in every round out of the
remaining candidates she's been widely
seen as a front runner throughout the
race is a moment for all of us let's
come together and challenge the status
quo let's give our party the Fresh Start
we need with serious leadership for all
of
[Applause]
us cromy has a lot riding on her
shoulders after the party's
underwhelming third place performance in
the last two IAL elections the Ontario
liberals will be looking for her to turn
their fortunes around against Premier
Doug
Ford canid top Admirals concerns about
the critical state of the country's Navy
coming up our conversation with Canada's
defense minister on the resource
shortage in a video released this week
Canada's top Admiral warned the roal
Canadian Navy is in a critical State and
might not be able to carry out its basic
duties next year vice admiral Angus topi
outlined severe concerns about the
Navy's personnel and Equipment including
ships that are beyond their life cycles
and a Severe shortage of sailors to
operate them our Mercedes Stevenson has
more on the federal government's
response to this Mercedes far this week
on the west block defense minister Bill
Blair joins me to answer some questions
about the government's plan for the the
military Blair acknowledged there are
problems but was kg over whether that
means the government will spend more on
defense I hope I've made it very clear
um publicly that we recognize we must do
more we're going to do more but there's
also some context in in in the doing
that more because there is a fiscal
situation in Canada that I have I have
to be realistic about what can be
achieved there have been some positives
the procurement of the Aurora aircraft
replacement has been greenlighted but
Blair did not answer when the Liberals
will replace the Canadian Army's Leopard
2 tanks that were donated to Ukraine of
course we've identified you know all of
our requirements with with respect of
those tanks we know what we want the
leopard tank and and and and we've we've
got we're also making investments in
maintaining the ones we've got but we do
know we need more but tanks are not the
only thing on the military's wish list
senior commanders say Canada only has 3
days worth of ammunition in its
stockpile that's 27 days short of the
NATO requirement another issue I put to
the minister we've been working on what
have been their challenges in acquiring
the ammunition and and some of it is is
resource but an awful lot of it is is
process procurement challenges are very
real and they're not new but military
sources are concerned the slow movement
isn't about the system but rather
political willingness to spend the feds
have already announced over a billion
dollars in defense Cuts so I asked Blair
if we can expect money for the mil
in the spring budget last year the
Canadian Armed Forces was was unable to
spend over two billion of their budget
and it's because their Pro the processes
of proc of procurement um are not as
efficient as they need to be whether or
not the government will invest more into
National Defense will have to wait until
that budget comes down next year
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
Mercedes and you can watch the full
interview with defense minister Bill
Blair tomorrow on the west block right
here on
global ah Hadad more women than men have
Alzheimer's disease so why is that not
being reflected in the research that's
[Music]
next gender Equity is a priority in many
aspects of society but in medical
science there is still a long way to go
data shows women suffer from depression
strokes and dementia twice as much as
men but despite that experts say there's
a notable gender gap when it comes to
research as Captain Ward explained
Advocates want more of a focus on women
in order to better understand the brain
5 years ago Sarah whitmire's mother
Elaine was diagnosed with Alzheimer's at
the age of 78 she died last year it was
like watching someone was tearing mom
apart bit by bit every day every
interaction Sarah says the disease was
unforgiving and changed her mom's world
she started to isolate herself and at at
a very time where probably she needed
more and more social interaction and her
own I think one of the biggest
challenges as a caregiver is that you
you feel isolated and alone experts say
almost 70% of those living with
Alzheimer's are women but funding for
treatment is sometimes based on old
outdated research there was always a
difficulty in recruiting a female in
clinical trials and so you had a huge
representation and with a lot of men and
very few women neuroscientist Vivian Pon
says some progress has been made in
recent years there's regulation for
clinical trials now to we try to have as
many men and women enrolled in the
clinical trials yes there's progress
because we started from zero but it's
still not enough because there's still
some gap of funding women's brain health
initiative founder Lynn pusin says it's
critical to build on this momentum we're
just at the start the start of this it's
it's a long journey and it does take um
a tremendous amount of support in order
to make sure that that the researchers
aren just topping up their research by
considering section gender but are
building it in from the Grassroots of
their research research that one day
might help families like Sarah's now
left holding on to memories oh she's all
around us she's in Christmas she's in
Halloween she's in the kitchen she's
here
now she's with us
always Katherine Ward Global
[Music]
News next kangaroo still on the loose
new details on how the marsupial went
missing and where it could
[Music]
be in Ontario the search continues for a
runaway kangaroo that managed to escape
her handlers while traveling to Quebec
The Fugitive marup has been spotted many
times since she got loose on Thursday
and though it's hopped up a little
excitement for locals crews are very
focused on getting her back safely and
as fast as they can Matthew Bingley
reports Cameron PR never thought he'd be
spending his Friday chasing a kangaroo
through a frozen field it wasn't too fun
uh I was doing my best but uh you know
I'm just a guy with a net the female red
kangaroo has been on the loose since
Thursday when it escaped from its
handlers during a stop at the aswa zoo
well on route to Quebec dozens have
spotted the out ofpl animal since then
he just kind of walked up to it and the
kangaroo ran off right after so yeah he
he didn't really have a chance no
definitely not the I kangar are much
faster than humans haah watched and
recorded as Pride out tried to Wrangle
the ru one of the last to see it on
Friday she's hoping more resources are
added to the search I was more just
concerned ER for the kangaroo because it
was like it obviously doesn't know the
area so we kind of just like felt bad
for it cuz also there's coyotes and
stuff in that areas the search has
primarily been focused around the
location it was last spotted Northeast
of ashaa but those looking for it admit
they don't know if it's still there and
after a thermal imaging drone came up
without a sighting the area may now be
in has likely expanded PR says red
kangaroos are mostly active at Dusk and
Dawn and it's un likely it's gone too
far these kangaroos can handle uh
temperatures up to about -10 at that
point in time it gets to be very risky
so we're hoping that this warm spell
kind of lasts long enough so that we can
get a hold of this creature and get it
uh back safe and sound he's also hoping
enough people have heard about the
missing creature to adjust their speed
while driving and that local Wildlife
like coyotes won't be another Factor
they have to worry about kangaroos are
incredibly soft they're so wonderful
and I feel terrible that this thing is
out there somewhere and I really just
want to try and get it back for now
everyone is waiting on a sighting and
for someone to call it in so this
bizarre Escape can end on a happy tone
Matthew Bingley Global
News and that's global national for
Saturday night I hope it's found I'm far
ner on behalf of our whole crew here I
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your evening with us and we have
a treat tonight tonight's your Canada is
this stunning display of northern lights
over St Martin Manitoba on Friday night
we love seeing your Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at
global.com Eric Sorenson will be on the
anchor desk tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good
night
[Music]